[موسيقى]
أعتقد أن الطبيعة لا تحتاج إليك ،
فنحن بحاجة إلى
الطبيعة وإه بالنسبة للشركات التي تقدم nava
أصولًا من الطبيعة ، فإن
nava في مهمة لإعادة الاتصال
بالطبيعة ونريد جلب فوائد
الطبيعة وقوة الطبيعة في الداخل
[  الموسيقى]
نحن الشركة الرائدة عالميًا في ثلاث
فئات ، الأولى هي الجدران الخضراء الحية ،
ثم الأثاث مع النباتات الحية ،
ثم التقنيات البيولوجية لتنقية الهواء الداخلي ،
هذا
النوع من الأثاث من الجدران الخضراء يشبه
آلات هواء الغابة
ولدينا 15 من تلك الموجودة
في  جناح فنلندي لجلب
هواء الغابة الرائع إلى الداخل
مع جدران نافا الخضراء ، لدينا تقنية
تجمع
بين الطبيعة والتصميم الاسكندنافي
المبسط
وقمنا بإنشاء هذا النظام الحاصل على براءة اختراع
حيث نرسم الهواء من خلال
نظام جذر النباتات ونستفيد من
الميكروبات في تنقية الهواء.
هذه المرشحات الحيوية عديمة التربة
لدينا مائة
ضعف كفاءة تنقية هواء النباتات مما يعني أن
أثاثًا واحدًا مثل نافا هو نفسه
هكتار  فنحن قادرون على إنشاء آلاف النباتات في غرفة
ما ، فنحن قادرون على إنشاء هذه الغابة ، حيث يعمل الهواء الرائع على
تحسين الرطوبة ومن ثم أه
ندعم رفاهية
وإنتاجية هؤلاء الأشخاص حيث يقضون
معظم وقتهم ، لذا فهذه
طريقة سلبية لتعزيز الفعالية.
يكون موظفوك في بيئة المكتب
في أفضل حالاتهم ، خاصة في هذه
الأوقات التي يعمل فيها الأشخاص من المنزل
وما إلى ذلك ، فهذه طريقة
لجذب الأشخاص ليكونوا في بيئة صحية
أه محاطة بالطبيعة
والعلم واضح من  إن وجود
الهواء الطبيعي والطبيعة في
الداخل يجعلك أكثر صحة وسعادة
وأكثر إنتاجية ، حيث
يمكنك التحكم في خططك باستخدام
البرنامج أو التطبيق الذي
نقدمه وهو مدمج مع
نظام إضاءة نظام الري
ونظام تهوية الهواء ، لذا فهو نوع من
الاتصال  جهاز يجعل
جودة الهواء الداخلي مثلى من
وجهة نظر صحة الإنسان وإه لهذا السبب
نريد تقديم الطبيعة كخدمة
حتى يسهل الاستمتاع بالمزايا  s
وقوة التخصصات
[موسيقى]